elles sont arrivées triomphantes à
l'Élysée une trè étoile sur le maillot
les hand balleuse tricolor sont devenu
dimanche championne du monde un sacre
offert par lena grandanveau 20 ans et
déjà
superstar dans les 5 dernières minutes
du match elle enchaîne les buts 4 en
tout et libère la France des
Norvégiennes jours
aprèsonoise vient sur son exploit il a
fallu un petit un petit TER de génie
parce que bah malgré tout je pense
qu'elle s'y attendait pas fallait que je
profite du moment fallit exciter
l'instant présent et une finale
championnat du monde ça se joue pas 10
fois dans une vite c'est trop beau en
fait pour y croire on dirait qu' on est
dans un rêve et que on n'est pas
réveillé quoi et non franchement c'est
c'est incroyable cette sensation bah de
fierté malgré tout arrivé en équipe de
France en septembre 2022 son succès est
foudroyant et ne surprend en personne au
bon handball le club de ses débuts on se
souvient d'une enfant prodige des toutes
petites on voyait bien qu'il y avait
quelque chose en plus voilà elle avait
déjà l'instinct
elle courait partout la vision tout
était déjà là c'est une vie qu'on
pouvait mettre partout sur le terrain on
la mettait arrière on la mettait à
l'elle et même à un moment si on voulait
même gagner un match et ben on pouvait
la mettre dans le but parce qu'on savait
que aucun but allait passer quoi un
élément stratégique est décisif pour le
club où un tiers des licenciés sont des
femmes elle fait encore plus que ce
qu'on lui prédisait parce que elle a une
maturité exceptionnelle pour son âge et
puis ben si elle pouvait servir de
modèle beaucoup de jeunes ce serait très
bien c'est un rêve on espère que les
autres y arriveront Lena grandveau elle
attend patiemment les Jeux Olympiques
pour porter ses couleurs encore plus
haut